we were made aware of the audio
between tariq and crystal
we were made of this information um in
real time just like the general public
we were deeply disturbed
by what we heard we were
deeply concerned um now obviously we
um have great concern for crystal we are
greatly concerned for
tyrique but our main focus and our main
concern is with the young child
um as soon as the draft concluded after
the last pick um i had the chance to
call drew rosenhaus
and we decided that
at this time um and for the first
foreseeable future tyrique will not take
part in any team activities um we are
going to gather more information we're
going to evaluate this information and
we will make the right decision
regarding tyree kill
that's chiefs general manager brett
veach after round one ended last night
they didn't have a pick in round one he
came out specifically to address the
tyrae kill situation took no questions
but said plenty and chris the audio we
caught wind of it an hour before it was
released i remember being very skeptical
like is it going to be hard to hear is
it going to be choppy what's the quality
going to be is it going to be clear that
that there's something being said by
tyreek hill that is in any way
incriminating and if you haven't
listened to the audio
we have a link to it at
profotballtalk.com
all you have to do is listen to it one
time it's troubling it's over the top
it it is something that cries out for
swift and immediate justice from the
authorities and from a national football
league chris that is committed to
policing the private lives of its
players that is something the nfl
decided years ago to do and in a
situation like this the nfl needs to act
swiftly i know the timing is unfortunate
because the draft is happening but the
league has to do something and the
chiefs have to do something they've done
something by telling him don't come to
offseason workouts brett veach ended by
saying they will make the right decision
in my mind there is only one right
decision by the chiefs that is to cut
tyreke hill now and there's only one
right decision by the nfl it is to
banish him under the personal conduct
policy for good chris your thoughts yeah
i i mike i can't really disagree with
a whole lot i mean you know again you
know banish them forever okay yeah i
mean i guess i'm about there too i'm
kind of
flushing this out in my own brain as we
go he's kind of reached that that level
certainly i mean come on this audio
recording this was like movie gangster
stuff like hitman stuff i don't know the
way to really you know paraphrase it or
say it but certainly troubling uh with a
guy who you know again had a troubled
history already where you know you
barely gave him the benefit of the doubt
or i didn't really give him the benefit
of the doubt i just thought oh gosh
maybe he was a young kid and emotions
got the best of him and his fiancee and
who knows what happened uh
so here we are with this with a young
child who has a broken arm and then you
hear some of the specifics about what
the fiance says and says the little boy
he doesn't respect you he fears you and
things like that all troubling uh i
can't ever root for tyree kill again
brett veach andy reed are stand-up human
beings i think you and i would both
agree with that people i really like
just as people and i would be shocked if
they didn't end this uh arrangement
between them and tyree kill and and i'm
with you i don't know if tyree kill ever
plays it down in the nfl ever again
well remember this they cut kareem hunt
in november after a video came to light
showing him shoving and kicking a woman
in a hallway of a cleveland hotel back
in february of 2018 and the reason they
cut him is because he had lied to them
he had said i didn't even go out of my
apartment i didn't walk out there i
didn't do anything so i don't know what
tyree kill had told the chiefs but there
was a statement issued yesterday from
tyreek hill that he was cooperative with
authorities he didn't invoke his fifth
amendment rights when he spoke to law
enforcement about what happened to his
son and i can only surmise that he lied
to them right otherwise charges would
have been filed if he had told the truth
about breaking his three-year-old son's
arm which is what cries out from the
audio conversation between him and
crystal espinal so the chiefs at a
minimum could easily get to the same
spot they got to in late november with
kareem hunt and say this guy's lied to
us he's gone he's not going to be here
and i call on them to do it immediately
not and look i'm i'm fine with last
night the half step he's not going to be
at offseason workouts okay good we're
going to make the right decision i don't
know what more information they need to
gather chris but whatever it is gather
it and then move on from tyree kill and
just i look
again i say go listen to the audio but
think about this
in one of the clips
tyreke and crystal espinal are arguing
over whether or not the boy is terrified
of tyree kill or whether or not the boy
respects tyree kelly right crystal
espinal continues to say he's terrified
of you and in the midst of this argument
yes tyree kell all of a sudden says you
need to be terrified of me too i'm with
you that is chilling that for me that
was the moment that's the moment where i
say this guy's unfit to play in the nfl
and i know there's going to be people
who say hey look the guy deserves
another chance well it's not a second
chance it's a third chance because of
what he did in college when he beat and
choked crystal espenor pleaded guilty to
it but any time one of these guys gets a
second chance remember there are only 1
696 jobs in the national football league
every time you give a guy a second
chance you are taking away the first
chance of a guy who never did anything
wrong and we never point that out and
i'm going to start mentioning that any
time a guy starts getting himself in
position for a second chance you're
going to be hurting another guy who
never did anything close to what this
guy has done yeah no there's that's
exactly right you know you've met a lot
of players you and i both know that the
majority of the players in the nfl are
great guys really are great you know
family men community people all that
tyree kill is not one of them and he is
one of the best players in the nfl and i
don't know how the nfl would stand for
having a guy like this as being one of
their best players in the nfl with the
actions we've seen very troubling and
yes kansas city chiefs need to cut ties
with them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports